tao fait françois je fais un nouveau
titre
fait un clip allez un truc simple on a
peur on reste humbles temps qu'elle
[Musique]
et ça lui j'en avais quand c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mans
encore je suis toujours aussi content de
vous retrouver sur cette chaîne c'est
chez nous on parle de faire des vidéos
de matos de montage de tournage et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ça va être un
petit peu particulier parce que là là on
vous a réservé quelque chose de
commander
connaissait jean michel toujours plus
passé et oui aujourd'hui on va parler du
z9 surtout d'un tournage en fait que
j'ai réalisé il ya quelques temps dans
des conditions pas vraiment ordinaire
donc je dis que c'était quand même
plutôt sympa de vous raconter un petit
peu cette expérience et au passage de
vous parler un petit peu de ce fameux
nikon 19 qui vient de sortir qui vient
d'être annoncé au moment où cette vidéo
elle est publiée je précise au passage
que cette vidéo n'est pas sponsorisé si
vous avez vu la vidéo précédente vous
savez de quoi je parle et que donc tout
ce qui sera dit dans cette vidéo c'est
purement et simplement mon avis et cette
vidéo c'est surtout une réaction à chaud
vraiment une réaction de terrain de voir
un petit peu la sensation que j'ai eu
avec ce boîtier alors ce qu'on va
tourner c'est un clip pour bé une
nouvelle nomade session vous rappeler
justement on en avait parlé par rapport
aux black magic raw et cette fois ci on
est allé encore plus loin mais avant de
vous montrer des extraits de ce clip je
vais vous raconter un petit peu comment
tout ça c'est goupil et pourquoi on a
utilisé le zen il ya quelques temps ben
justement on envoie un message me dit
bas et j'ai trouvé un spot pour la
prochaine oman session ça peut être cool
c'est le pic du midi de bigorre georges
claouey je me dis ok très bien et là ils
m'envoient des photos et on voit qu'il
ya quand même une passerelle au dessus
du vide à 3000 m d'altitude
je veux dire il ya un truc à faire
alignement de planètes coup de téléphone
ni co2 m'appelle et me dit à françois on
aimerait bien de faire tester le z9
t'aurais pas un tournage un peu sympa
prévue dans quelques temps
comment vous dire oui totalement du coup
une icône dans la boucle et moi je me
dis bon bah on peut faire des plans de
drone un petit peu sympa et tout mais il
ya peut-être moyen d'aller un petit peu
plus loin puisque quand on avait fait le
tournage du lancement du set 6 2 il y
avait des télés pilote qui faisait du
drone fpv c'était juste ou faux dessus
de la dune du pilat donc je me dis
pourquoi pas et donc je leur demande
s'ils peuvent faire venir un thé les
pilotes qui va nous faire du fpv à 3000
m d'altitude tout en haut du pic du midi
ils ont dit oui et donc france havas
était content et je vous fais pas plus
attendre avant de vous parler un petit
peu d'espèces du boîtier de ce qu'on a
utilisé des réglages qu'on avait je vous
demande tout de suite un extrait du clip
[Musique]
c'est pas mal et vous pouvez retrouver
l'intégralité du clip il est en lien
dans la description la musique est
incroyable c'est signé ben toujours
c'est vraiment boisjot tiff c'est un
projet qui me plaît bref allez voir et
donnez-lui beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'amour donc pour tourner ce clip la
question qui s'est posée c'est quelle
définition on va utiliser est-ce qu'on
va filmer en 4k ou envie cas puisqu'il
fait de l'avicca je suis pas un grand
fan de l'avicca d'ailleurs le workflow a
été assez lourd j'ai pas encore mon
nouveau macbook pro m1 max donc mes
ordis ont un petit peu souffler quand
même hein faut dire ce qui est ils ont
un petit peu souffert labica c'est lourd
mais on a choisi de le faire en 8k parce
qu'on saisit pourquoi pas tant qu'être
dans un lieu où fut comme il est autant
shooter envie cas pour au moins voir par
curiosité ce que ça donne et c'est
plutôt pratique notamment pour recadrer
un petit peu pour croquer c'est quand
même assez cool et puis c'était aussi
une manière de pousser un petit peu le
boîtier dans ses retranchements pour
pouvoir voir vraiment ce qu'il avait
dans le ventre pas de surchauffe ça a
marché nickel j'ai pas été un bon
boîtier de 4 4,5 heures la batterie a
tenu c'était assez incroyable pour ce
qui est du drone fpv bien les mecs ils
ont fixé directement le z9 sur le drone
fpv juste incroyable on a réussi à avoir
des plans de ouf il avait monté dessus
de mémoire le 14 30 f4 nikon qui est
bien un grand-angle très léger et ben
alors est-ce qu'il ya besoin de le
commenter le rendu est ce que ce que
s'il ya besoin de dire quelque chose là
dessus le tournage comment il s'est
passé c'était très simple on a installé
ben au bout de la passerelle
on a relié ces claviers tout ça et
ensuite on a fait les prises au sol donc
méprise j'ai utilisé le z9 avec un 24 70
pour pouvoir faire plusieurs prises à
différentes valeurs focal pour pouvoir
arrimer blanc on lançait le playback
j'ai filmé de mémoire à 24 à 50 et à 70
mm pour avoir trois valeurs de plantes
différentes ensuite je suis allé de
l'autre côté de la plate forme pour être
beaucoup plus loin pour pouvoir avoir
des plans aux 70 200 et là j'ai été très
surpris parce que j'étais à main levée
j'avais zappé de prendre un monopôle
complètement ça m'était totalement sorti
de l'esprit donc je tenais cet énorme z9
là puisqu'il a un double grippe avec le
soixante dix deux sens a pesé très lourd
je me disais à 200 mm l'image va faire
ça je vais rien pouvoir avoir 100
monopode est en fête eh bien c'était
assez impressionnant la stabilisation
qu'on pouvait avoir à main levée sans
post prod j'ai trouvé que c'était
vraiment bien foutu bon par contre
c'était très lourd et c'est peut-être
aussi un des défauts faut bien en
trouver de 16,9 sais que ça n'a rien à
voir avec un z 6 ou un 7 7 c'est quand
même beaucoup plus lourd mais c'est pas
non plus la même cible mais ça on y
reviendra un petit peu après en même
temps pour embarquer tout ce qu'ils
embarquent dedans je pense que dans un
tout petit boîtier comme le semis du z 6
ou du 7 sept ça aurait été compliqué
pour la partie montage proxy
obligatoires c'était c'était c'était
évident c'était couru d'avancé puisque
on a fait du multicam donc il y avait
cinq ou six flux multicam en 8k pour
l'instant c'est compliqué de trouver un
ordinateur qui puisse faire tourner ça
comme ça sans proxy sans rien mais bon
au final ça a marché et on a eu notre
clip en vie car on s'est posé la
question aussi de savoir si on allait
pas plutôt tournés en 4k mais cette fois
ci en prores parce que oui le z9 il
propose de faire de la 4k 60 images par
seconde en interne en prores rappelé a
aussi j'avais fait le pari que le
progrès salah arrivé dans les boîtiers
et bassa a pas loupé la 4k en prores
c'est dispo en interne dans le dico des
neuf et ça c'est plutôt cool pour le
coup le workflow aurait peut-être été un
peu plus adapté je pense que si j'avais
dû utiliser ça plusieurs fois de manière
récurrente je serai peut-être partie
plutôt sur du port est ce parce que là
le multicam ça aurait été caviardé vu
que c'est le codec natives qui est dans
la timeline de fans il que si j'avais
pas été curieux de tester la wicca je
serais parti là dessus mais aussi des
plans de drones au ralenti en 120 images
par seconde en 4k et j'ai pas précisé
mais à toutes ces résolutions à tous ces
framerate eh bien on a des codecs en cas
de 2 10 bits partout en 8k en cas de
casse un fps voilà c'est de la cat de 2
10 bits tout le temps en codec h 264
groupe comme on a vu précédemment
carrément en province et d'ailleurs il y
avait là me emmanuel pampuri qui étaient
avec nous pour faire le making of le
bnde signe d'ailleurs il a sorti lui
aussi une ideo qui s'affiche ici ou là
que je vous encourage à aller voir parce
qu'il va aller encore plus loin dans la
technique que moi au niveau de la post
prod et de l'étalonnage y avait vraiment
beaucoup plus de marge que ce que j'ai
sur mon z6 alors je sais pas si le n log
a été retravaillée par rapport aux and
lobe qu'on peut avoir sur l'atome hausse
n'empêche que je les trouvais vraiment
très bon alors que ben sur l'atome aux
songes était plus fan du projet 0 que du
1 blog parce qu'ils avaient tendance à
brut et un petit peu là vraiment je les
trouvais vraiment bien fichu les
couleurs là on voit vraiment qu'on est
passé sur lucas de diby de samassa a
rien à voir avec le cadre de 0 8 bits ce
qu'on a en interne sur 1 7 6 on a
beaucoup plus de nuances les choses
ressortent beaucoup mieux enfin il n'y
avait pas grand chose à à tweeté dans
les profils d'image pour réussir à avoir
quelque chose de chouette j'ai même
retrouver cette sensation un petit peu
que j'ai avec le black magic raw sortie
du z 6 en termes d'image en termes de
couleurs donc c'est quand même très
appréciable parce qu'au final 7-6 plus
enregistreurs blackmagic + disque dur là
aussi ça commence à faire un budget mais
c'est vrai que là j'avais besoin du
boîtier de mon optique et de rien
d'autre on a donc vu que les codecs sont
vraiment très très bien mais il va
falloir prévoir les cartes cf express en
conséquence déjà que c'est cher falloir
quand même prendre au moins du 250 gigas
si c'est pas du 500 en tout cas pour la
8 k environ pour une heures de rushes
faut compter 2 100 giga ce qui est pas
délirant quand on voit le poids du
bureau ou durée de code c'est plutôt
correct je m'attendais à beaucoup plus
gros mais dès qu'on va passer en
province en internat les fichiers vont
devenir très très très très gros donc si
vous comptez utiliser ce boîtier est ce
genre d'enregistrement il faudra quand
même penser au budget carte aussi parce
que ça va commencer à chiffrer un autre
truc que je voulais vous raconter il m'a
fait un petit peu bizarre c'est qu'avec
mari on a fait quelques photos aussi une
des nouveautés de ce z9 c'est qu'il n'y
a plus d'observateur mécanique et ça
c'est très très très déstabilisant parce
que quand on déclenche pour la photo on
a un petit bruit de haut parleurs qui
fait kiffer le bruit du déclencheur mais
il ya plus de déclencheur mécanique
l'obturateur il est électronique 100% du
temps ce qui fait qu'on peut shooter je
crois jusqu'à 120 images par seconde
en jpeg des rafales de tahar est sain
qu'il y ait le moindre bruit et ça c'est
déstabilisant mais d'un autre côté je me
dis que ça peut permettre d'être discret
pour des gens qui font de l'animalier ou
du mariage ou du concert le fait de
pouvoir prendre des photos en faire
aucun bruit je pense que ça peut être un
avantage bon moi je fais pas trop de
photos mais c'était amusant à tester
nikon annonce aussi avoir un rolling
shutter le plus rapide enfin le moins
visible de toutes les appareils photos
du marché donc ça ça peut être pas mal
alors là dessus j'ai pas fais des tests
poussés pour savoir si vraiment c'est
aussi fantastique que ça mais c'est
sensé se rapprocher du global chanteur
qu'on retrouve par exemple sur une
arrête enfin il faut parler des choses
qui fâchent le prix enfin qui fâchent
pour moi c'est un boîtier très haut de
gamme qu'on retrouve chez chaque
constructeur on a le r3 chez cannon on à
l'alpha one chez sony on a maintenant le
z9 chez nikon c'est vraiment le haut du
panier et le prix s'en ressentent
forcément faudra compter environ 6000
euros pour acheter le z9 et c'est sur
que c'est pas à la portée de tout le
monde on rajoute à ça les optiques les
cartes cf express de très grande taille
ça fait 2 suite un grand budget et on en
arrive à la question fatidique est-ce
que je vais acheter ce z9 et la réponse
est les roulements de tambour non alors
non pas qu'ils soient pas bien et que
j'ai été déçu bien au contraire c'était
une super expérience d'avoir ces codecs
interne et d'être vraiment juste avec le
boîtier sans rien autour j'aime beaucoup
shooté sans accessoirisation parce que
je me sens plus libre de mes mouvements
je trouve ça vachement plus sympa
certains moments j'avais juste me
peut-être une poignée sur la griffe pour
pouvoir avoir une prise en plus au
dessus mais c'est vraiment où il y avait
rien d'autre et ça c'était un pur
bonheur maintenant je pense que je suis
pas la cible de ceux z9 clairement c'est
un boîtier qui pour moi fait tout c'est
à dire qu'en photo il est monstrueux
mari s'est régalé c'était vraiment assez
ouf l'autofocus marche vraiment bien le
suivi le tracking s'est vraiment
améliorée depuis le set 6-2 peut-être
qu'on retrouvera toutes ces technologies
et 6 3 ce qui serait vraiment cool
l'autonomie elle est juste dingue hein
j'ai pas changer de batterie dans la
journée donc en filmant mika enfin c'est
juste juste incroyable bref ce boîtier
il a tout il coche toutes les cases mais
personnellement j'ai pas le besoin
d'avoir ce type de boîtier donc je
pourrais tout revendre et prendre un z 9
mais bon peut-être me calmer un petit
peu sur les achats en ce moment parce
que bon on va rester raisonnable mais ça
n'empêche que ce boîtier il fait tout
bien la contrepartie c'est le prix
forcément si on veut un boîtier qui fait
tout et qu'il le fait hyper bien eh bien
il faut y mettre le prix est là
clairement je pense que les 6000 euros
il les vaut c'est un boîtier qui défonce
sa race mais qui est un petit peu
surdimensionné par rapport à mes besoins
et ce qui n'est pas surdimensionné par
rapport à un besoin c'est le coup de
double hester sur le pouce en l'air qui
se situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
le fait de sa bonne et le fait d'aller
voir cette vidéo là qui vous parle un
petit peu du bureau avec le set 6-2 et à
quel point c'est cool que sans avoir de
z9 on peut aussi arriver à faire des
trucs vraiment vraiment sympa et moi les
amis je vous dis rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
ciao